it's being called New Delhi's air
pocalypse the air is so toxic in the
Indian capital a city of 18 million
people that a public health emergency
has now been declared schools are shut
all construction work has been ordered
to stop and flights have been diverted
or delayed on Sunday the air quality
index hit its worst level for the year
at 494 that's nearly 10 times the safe
level of 50 delhi chief minister says
the pollution has reached critical
levels how do they keep the charter of
the wide why they were smoke everywhere
and people including youngsters kids the
elderly they're all finding it difficult
to breathe eyes are burning the
pollution is that bad well private cars
with number plates ending in an odd
number have been temporarily banned from
the roads that's taken away a chunk of
the more than 10 million registered
vehicles in New Delhi a government study
says the transport sector is the biggest
contributor to the city's pollution
levels while also being blamed farmers
from neighboring states they burn their
stubble at this time of year after
October to clear their fields for the
coming winter crop and shelve Ora has
more now from New Delhi that's the
iconic rashtrapati bhavan or President's
House in New Delhi it's a tall massive
building and a to spot but today one can
barely see it it is engulfed in smog as
is the rest of the city I've been
standing here for barely 20 minutes my
eyes are burning and the back of my
throat is itching and it isn't just me
doctors in the city say that many more
patients are visiting them with ailments
that can be attributed to air pollution
do what they say Olivia mas I've been
using this mask for a couple of days
it's a bit inconvenient for sure but
when I'm traveling on the road then with
this pollution my eyes start to water
the Delhi government has taken a step to
reduce the number of personnel we
at the national capital and hence reduce
vehicular pollution the volunteers
who've been deployed on this traffic
square tell us that the people actually
are following it the government has also
given these mosques but few people are
wearing it it is rather inconvenient but
mainly as long as farmers and
neighboring states do not stop burning
the stubble pollution in the national
capital is expected to continue to
remain very severe
well let's pause for a second try to
understand exactly how damaging the air
in New Delhi is today let's remind you
how it rates on the air quality index
that measures the health risks
associated with air pollution under 50
is generally considered to be good 40 to
100 is moderate above that there are
serious health risks with everything
above 400 considered to be hazardous for
comparison Berlin German capital the
city of around three and a half million
people sits around 21 on the same index
New Delhi on the other hand is right now
sitting between 400 and 700 in some
parts of the city that far exceeds the
limit that anyone should be breathing
karthik ganesha is a research fellow at
the Council on Energy Environment and
water
he says farmers are contributing to the
smog but they need help to move to
greener practices the problem of air
pollution in Delhi is a multi-pronged
one it's not just one item what we're
hearing today is of course that farmers
in Punjab are burning crop residue and
as a result air quality in Delhi is
deteriorated but for much of the year
more than three hundred days out of the
365 Delhi is actually breathing really
bad quality air it never really gets the
news the way it does in the winter
months so clearly the problem is much
beyond just the issue of you know the
crop burning that happens you know for
about four weeks or so in the winters
there's a host of problems that need to
be addressed really if you have to get
this right blaming the farmer is sort of
like not exactly the best thing that one
can be do at this point in time but the
fact is that they've been incentivized
by the cheap availability of basically
free electricity and the water that
they're able to pump with it and then
grow a crop that's technically not
sustainable in the part of the country
where it is being grown which is rice
right
and as a result what's really happened
is that you know it's lead to it's led
to depletion of the water table and
probably they won't be able to cultivate
rise to the extent that they are in
another decade or so because the water
table would have gone really low right
and it's because of the fact that
there's this rice wheat crop cycle that
they're doing that we're seeing the
problem currently and the solution
really lies in sort of going back to I
think you know multi cropping and
diversifying what you actually produce
through the year and not relying just in
one crop